(laughing)
(upbeat guitar music)
- I love yoga.
So, and I love laughing,
so I'm really excited
to put them together.
- I like laughing.
Yoga, I'm indifferent to.
- To be frank, I have no idea
what the fuck's going on here.
I have no idea what's gonna happen today.
- I'm sure this is echoed
by my fellow testees,
but this is weird.
- I fill like I won't be
able to keep it together.
- For some reason I have this image,
in my brain that like,
we're all just gonna
sit in a circle like,
criss-cross applesauce.
(gong resonating)
- Namaste.
I'm a yoga teacher.
That's what yogis say, right?
- Sure.
- Yeah, I'm here to introduce
you guys to laughter yoga.
- What does that entail?
- What is that?
- Laughter yoga it's just basically
getting together and
laughing for no reason.
- Do you like break a sweat?
- No, not necessarily.
You just break a chuckle.
- That's great.
- A chuckle?
- Break a chuckle!
- The first thing I wanna
teach you is after every game,
we're gonna do this.
You're gonna go "Very
good, very good, yay!"
(laughing)
Try it.
- [All together] Very
good, very good, yay!
- For some reason I had in my mind
that we were gonna be
doing a lotta exercises.
But it was really more just sillyness.
- So we're gonna go to a
laughter party, alright?
So you're gonna imagine that
you're sleeping in your bed,
and imagine you're having a funny dream.
Just laugh to yourself.
(soft fake laughing)
And let's go into the shower.
And you know, you have a laughter shower,
so when you turn on the water,
you have laughter water.
(forced laughing)
- He had the most infectious
laughter I've ever heard.
Like I feel like part of why I lost myself
was because he had such a great laugh
that I just lost it (laughing).
(loud, goofy laughing)
- Okay.
- [All together] Very
good, very good, yay!
- So lets go to the party, right?
So we're gonna go to our car.
You have one of these
old laughter cars, okay?
So, and it works kind of like,
you know those lawnmowers?
(choppy laughing)
It's a little old, so...
- As we just sort of
laughed more and more,
something about what was
happening was just so funny.
(forced laughing)
(laughing in rhythm)
(whoop-sounding laughing)
(maniacal laughing)
(laughing in rhythm)
It's so funny (laughing).
It doesn't make any sense.
(meditative humming)
- He told us we were gonna meditate.
- And I was kind of like,
oh I don't really know if I wanna end
this whole thing on like
a really calm meditation.
- And then, man...
- And then from very deep,
outside of outer space,
imagine a little giggle
rocket, coming towards you.
(laughing)
- When he said "Giggle rocket,"
I just lost my shit because, c'mon,
giggle rocket's a hilarious
phrase, in general.
(laughing)
- It's coming right towards Earth, guys.
It's the end of the world.
(laughing)
- Namaste.
- [All together] Namaste.
(fake laughing)
- I loved it all.
I would do this again.
- I feel like I just got a massage.
- I felt like I was high the
entire time I was doing that.
- I'm feeling pretty
charged up, okay Drake?
- That was perfect for someone like me,
who's giggling like 24/7 anyway.
- Being in it,
it just completely losing
yourself in the process,
is something that's hard
for me to do, to be honest,
and today, that actually happened.
So kudos to the laughter man.
- Very good, very good, yay!
- [Jen] He looked a
lot like Stanley Tucci.
A handsomer Stanley Tucci.
Don't show this to Stanley Tucci.
He'll get jealous.
- It's here, it's here!
- [All together] It's here!
- It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
- I think I got it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.